Good morning everybody.
We will be returning the exams on Thursday.
They're being graded now and we'll return them to you on Thursday and I've
always found a found in the past that uh,
having once we finished the midterm exam and all of you have had a chance to go
back over the material mastered,
it is the ideal time to begin to talk about a selection of a paper topic,
a term paper topic and I'm going to concentrate on that particular issue in
today's class.
The choice of a paper topic right before spring break is also a good time to
begin thinking about this because there are a lucky few of you in here who are
actually going to Rome for spring break and there are others that are heading
home to California,
pops possibly near Malibu,
might have a chance to go to the Getty museum in Malibu,
which is based on a,
a,
an important villa at ancient Roman villa at Herculaneum as well as other
travels that may give you some ideas about potential paper topics.
And don't underestimate just the experience of architecture of any period in
terms of inspiring you as you go to whatever city you're headed toward,
a or,
or even whatever small town you're headed toward.
Looking at what's around you can be a stimulation,
uh,
to making a selection on a paper topic.
Uh,
so I want to go over that with you today.
Also,
I'm going to show you some magnificent parts of the Roman Empire as a prelude to
what we'll be doing when we get back after spring break.
And that is,
although we'll spend,
we'll do one lecture on Hadrian and the Pantheon and Hadrian's Villa Tivoli and
one on a at colony in Italy,
namely Ostia,
uh,
the port of Rome.
From that point on,
we'll make our way around the rest of the Roman Empire will go to North Africa.
We'll go to Jordan.
I will go to the other parts of the Middle East.
Uh,
we'll go to France and Spain.
So we'll be spending spring,
uh,
going around the Roman Empire to mix to some extraordinary spots.
And I think by introducing you to some of those today,
uh,
with visa vi the paper topics,
we'll get you in the mood.
I hope for that kind of a whirlwind tour that we're going to take in the second
half of the semester.
I'd like to spend the rest of the time,
again showing you some magnificent places,
giving you a sense of the three options for the paper topics and specific
monuments and sights that I hope you'll think you'll consider as possibilities
for your paper.
And again,
as I mentioned,
it's also a good chance for us to begin to experience the provinces of the Roman
Empire.
Obviously I've chosen,
uh,
topics that are ones that for the most part,
there's one or two exceptions,
but for the most part are not topics that I'm going to be going over in class.
Uh,
so to give you an opportunity to look into a part of the world that we may not
cover in class,
uh,
but also to be able to,
um,
to use what you have learned about Roman buildings in general to decipher a
buildings that you haven't yet seen before.
The first of these,
well,
the first,
the first option,
there are three options as I mentioned before.
And option one is a straight forward research paper that is comparable obviously
to research papers that you've done.
Not only another art history courses,
but in other history courses and other whatever courses,
even science courses,
a straight research paper in which you have a topic that you do a considerable
amount of reading on,
a focused reading on that particular topic.
And,
um,
I give you a bibliography for all of these.
And by the way,
all of these,
pretty much all of these Biblia graphical sources are on reserve in the art and
architecture library for this course with a group this size.
Uh,
obviously if a number of you choose the same topic,
I don't want a situation and whoever the early bird catches the worm,
whoever gets the book out of sterling has it and nobody else can get to it.
So I have put the books on reserve for this course.
I know that creates other challenges because you can't take it home with you
but,
and it means you do need to share,
but it will mean that it will be there for you in the library.
And in some instances they're a second copies at the university.
So again,
in that sense,
the early bird can catch the worm if,
if there is a second or third copy that can be checked out.
So I do urge you,
if you have a pretty good sense of what it is that you may want to work on and
want to pick up a book or two before you leave for spring break,
uh,
the next couple of days would be the time to do that.
So the first topic,
so under research paper,
get a straightforward research paper in which you do some reading.
You do some looking,
you think about this monument,
you think about its uh,
its,
it,
its own special characteristics as well as where it fits into and the evolution
of Roman architecture and one hopes of course that you'll do both a synthetic
once you've done your reading and your research that you will present the,
the work this work of architecture synthetically.
Uh,
but at the same time I hope that you will have a thesis that there will be
something that you will come up with on your own.
Uh,
a major point,
the major focus that you'll want to have and that you'll want to make and that
you want to use the paper toward arguing some thesis of your own.
Even though for the most part it will be a synthesis of,
of what you read,
what's understood and a placement of it.
Since you now know Rome itself particularly well,
if you choose a topic of a,
of a building or a group of buildings that are outside Rome,
the relationship of what's going on,
on the periphery to what has,
what is going on in the center and the relationship up center to periphery.
So the first topic I give you under a research paper is the Roman city of
Corinth.
This which is in Greece.
This would be a good paper topic for the classicists among you.
And I know there are some,
uh,
anyone who's into who's fairly well steeped in Greek culture,
as well as Roman culture and civilization who might want to look back at,
at a Greek city,
a city that was already a very built up under the Greeks as early as the archaic
period.
This is a view,
for example,
of the Greek Greek archaic,
uh,
temple at Corinth.
So a Greek city,
a very well developed Greek city that is eventually taken over by the Romans.
And the Romans remake it,
uh,
in the Roman manner.
They add a typical Roman buildings to it create a kind of mini Rome in Greece.
But it's interesting to see the way in which those new buildings blend with
those that were built there earlier.
I also mentioned here not only the archaic,
uh,
temple at Corinth,
but also the so called isthmus at Corinth.
You might remember from our conversation about Julius Caesar and the
architecture that he built,
that Julius Caesar was the one who built a canal at the isthmus of Corinth and
the canal that is still visible and use used at Corinth today.
What you see,
an excellent view of on the lefthand side of the screen,
uh,
is essentially the same a canal that was built initially or began initially by
Julius Caesar.
So that gives you some sense of a Roman addition to the scene.
And I show you just one other example.
There are quite a number of buildings preserve from Corinth,
Roman buildings.
Uh,
so one could do it for a paper like this.
One could do an overview of the Roman city,
all the pieces of the Roman city,
how the urban fabric worked.
Or You could choose one or two buildings it at Corinth that Roman Corinth to
concentrate on.
I show you,
for example,
a view of the remains of the Roman baths at Corinth.
And what's interesting about these,
and you can pick this out on your own already just by looking at this one view.
What's interesting about these is although they look back to Roman bath
architecture in Italy,
uh,
you can see that this bath is made entirely of cut stone construction,
which is quite different from either the small bags we saw at Pompei pay,
the stop being baths or the forum beds or the later imperial baths.
The baths of Titus,
for example,
that we've already explored,
uh,
where concrete construction was used here.
Stone was used.
Why was stone use?
Because there was a very long tradition already begun in Greece from the archaic
period through the classical period to the Hellenistic period of using stone for
architecture and the architects in this particularly particular part of the
world.
Because stone was so readily available and is at,
especially marble,
but other kinds of stone as well,
so readily available.
Uh,
and because the,
the,
uh,
architects and designers in this part of the world,
we're so skilled at carving stone,
it was natural for them to use good stone in their construction.
So we see that they are not seduced by a concrete domes and the like don't use
concrete in their architecture,
which you're going to see not only today,
but in the future,
uh,
is really an Italian phenomenon.
Uh,
concrete is picked up very sparingly in the Roman provinces.
Stone construction tends to be the norm for the most part.
Uh,
and we see that at corn.
So the whole question of building materials,
uh,
becomes very important,
but one would ask oneself of one looked at the bas,
at Corinth for example,
what is the plan like?
How similar is it to the small,
uh,
bad's that we saw at palm pay?
How similar is it to,
uh,
the imperial bath of building that we saw,
the symmetrical and axial,
uh,
imperial Beth building that we saw,
for example,
under tight is what kinds of materials was it made out?
What is the layout of rooms,
the men too sections,
women's sections,
I mean,
all the obvious questions that you would want to put a to this particular
structure.
Also in the eastern part of the empire,
uh,
a,
the city of Ephesus in,
uh,
what was ancient Asia,
Asia minor modern took Turkey on the western coast of Turkey and extraordinary
place.
It too,
had a very long history,
uh,
not only,
historical and cultural and political,
uh,
but also in terms of its architecture.
A built up already in the Greek period just as Greece itself was a,
and the,
one of the most famous temples at ethicists,
uh,
was the temple of Artemis at Ephesus.
Uh,
and I show you a coin of that temple here.
It was renowned worldwide and pilgrims came from all over the Hellenistic and
Roman world to see it.
And I show you a representation on this coin of what the temple of Artemis in
emphasis looked like.
A,
and you can see here that it had eight columns across the front.
They were ionic columns at least at one point.
It was rebuilt over a number of years and that got changed over time.
Uh,
but we see it here with its ionic columns with its pedimento decoration and with
the columns,
uh,
spread out in the center in order to reveal the cult statue of Artemis.
And what a statue.
It was a,
I show it to you,
a copy of it,
very well endowed Artemis as you can see here on the left hand side of the
screen.
And there are tons and tons of copies of these and this is one of those that
gives us a very good sense of what this cult statue of Artemis in this famous
temple look like.
And you can see that she's had a very long afterlife.
It's,
it's very tempting to use her in all kinds of later ways.
And as you can see in this wonderful view of the villa desk day at Tivoli in
Italy,
which is very close to Hadrian's villa at Tivoli,
a renaissance,
uh,
area with lots of fountains and so on.
And you can see how they've taken the Artemis or Diana of Ephesus a and made her
into a fountain a so she comes up in all kinds of later context.
As you can see with regard to the Roman city,
uh,
the city of the Roman city of emphasis is extremely well preserved.
Uh,
it's one of the best preserved Roman cities today.
You know,
up there with places like palm pay and Herculaneum.
But as you can see from two buildings from emphasis,
it is very different from either Pompei or Herculaneum.
It is essentially a marble city.
Uh,
and it's another example of the fact that in Greece and in Asia minor,
uh,
marble construction and using the traditional language of architecture as
developed by the Greeks,
columns and pediments and walls and the roofs that they support,
uh,
remains,
the way of going about construction.
Uh,
and I show you here,
for example,
the very well preserved a arch of Augustus at Ephesus,
which gives you the sense,
uh,
of,
of uh,
of the kind of stone construction that was used for that.
And perhaps more interesting is the shrine that I show you over the Shriner,
the temple that I show you here on the right,
which is the temple of Hadrian,
the emperor Hadrian at emphasis that was put up in honor of Hadrian's,
a very small temple,
more a shrine a.
And what's interesting about it is again,
that it is made out of stone.
I mean,
think of this in relationship to the pet.
We haven't looked at it,
but I know it's a building you all know well,
the Pantheon in Rome,
which of course is a,
uh,
is,
is one of the greatest concrete buildings the Romans produced or is the greatest
concrete building the Romans produced.
If you compare that with its very large scale with its concrete construction to
this,
you get a very good sense of the difference between Rome and emphasis in the
Adriatic period.
This is again,
a very small building.
You can see it's made entirely of stone.
Uh,
it has columns,
it has pilasters,
uh,
it is very highly decorated,
in fact,
almost overly ornate with that decoration,
almost d materializing the architectural members.
And you can also see a motif that we have seen before in painting,
but never before in built architecture.
And that is a straight lintel and then an arcuate,
the occupation of the lintel and then the straight lintel again.
Uh,
and that is housed in a pediment or at least part of the pediment.
We can't tell,
but you can see on both sides,
the pediment begins to,
uh,
to rise.
Uh,
uh,
but it's not completed.
Now,
whether it's just broken off or whether it was what we would call a partial or
broken triangular pediment we're not absolutely certain.
My guess is it was a broken triangular pediment.
So we have this RQ weighted lintel emerging from the broken triangular pediment.
We're going to see that this motif of straight RQ weighted lintel very popular
in the Adriatic period and even brought to Italy,
uh,
from experiments in the east.
But again,
we saw this in painting,
we saw this in that painting that was on the midterm,
the uh,
cubic Yalom 16,
uh,
for example,
already in pain.
Now we see it in built architecture,
but we,
what we see in the eastern part of the empire is the way in which architects use
the traditional language of Greek architecture columns pediments lintels and do
something entirely different with them.
And it's very different from built architecture in Rome of the same period.
Now the building that I recommend,
if you want to work on emphasis,
there are other possibilities.
I mean,
you could work on that temple of Hadrian for example,
but the one that I think it has the richest opportunities for and outstanding
paper and an interesting paper as well.
An interesting research,
um,
uh,
adventure,
is the,
um,
library of calcis in Ephesus.
Your students,
you spend a lot of time,
my hope in libraries.
Uh,
and so you have a sense of,
of sterling and the way it works if you're not always online.
Instead of going to the library these days,
which is a temptation that,
that even I fall into the trap of on a fairly regular basis.
Uh,
but,
um,
you know,
using the Internet instead of taking that extra step to get to the library.
But I really urge,
it's very important for this topic.
You will not find for this these papers you will not find,
you will find a lot of interesting things on the Internet and I really do urge
you to use it.
But at the same time you will find that you really do need to go to the library
and get,
uh,
get out of variety of books to help you do a good job on this paper,
the library of Calcis,
uh,
because of your general interest in libraries and because of the fact that we
haven't been able to talk in this course about libraries in the ancient world,
the most famous of which of course was the library at Alexandria,
a upon all which all other ancient libraries appeared to have tried.
It appeared to have measured a themselves.
But we see lots of libraries in Rome and around Italy.
And around the empire,
a Greek and Latin libraries,
libraries that are either part of private villas.
Sometimes we'll see that at Hadrian's villa for example,
uh,
or in fora like Trojans forum,
which we'll look at on Thursday.
Uh,
but also a large enterprises that serve to city such as this one.
This is the library of calcis in uh,
emphasis.
It is called after calcis because Kelsey,
a man by the name of Kelsea's Cel sus was the patron of this particular library
that bears his name.
Uh,
he was the benefactor who wanted to splash his own name on this,
uh,
on this library.
The purpose of the library being a library for everybody who lived in,
uh,
in emphasis.
We see a plan.
These are both from Ward Perkins,
a plan a and also restored view of the interior.
In the plan you see it's inside,
it's a rectangular space with a niche,
with columns in that niche,
columns around the perimeter of room and then columns as well as a staircase on
the front of the structure.
In this restored view,
you get a better sense of what it would've looked like in,
in,
inside.
Uh,
you see that niche here.
You can see now that it's a two story niche with columns on two stories and with
a semi dome with coffers at the top.
And then a series of tears,
uh,
with,
with um,
rectangular,
uh,
storage areas here with shelves where they placed this member,
there was scrolls,
not books.
So they piled the scrolls on the shelves and then each of these rectangular
areas had a wooden door that would cover,
we would close and keep those scrolls protected unless,
uh,
and someone wanted to check them out or consult them,
or whatever we see.
It also had a flat roof with a coffered ceiling.
Now what's also very interesting about this library and essentially unique is
that Kelsey is not only wanted to give this,
uh,
as as a benefaction to his city for the public good.
He decided he also wanted it to serve as his tomb.
Now I've told you that,
that people made strange choices.
Visa vi their last resting places,
and Kelsey's decided that he wanted to be buried in his library.
So he provided beneath that central niche,
there was a burial chamber and he was indeed a buried in his library.
So this is not only a library,
it's also a tomb,
which again,
makes it a particularly interesting topic.
I believe it had fallen.
The building had fallen down and about in the 1970s it was still on the ground
in bits and pieces.
In more recent decades,
they have taken those pieces that were,
there were tons of them,
hundreds and hundreds of pieces.
And the authorities,
the archeological authorities have put this building back together,
but they put it back together with its own,
you know,
with its own architectural members and so on.
And this is what you see today.
If you go to emphasis,
it's an extraordinary structure.
Uh,
you can see that it's entirely made out of marble.
This is the facade of the library of Kelsey's.
It's entirely made out of marble.
We can see that it is two tiered,
uh,
with columns.
Uh,
supporting straight lintels down below.
And then in the upper tier,
uh,
combination of,
of arched,
uh,
and,
of,
um,
RQ weighted pediments and rectangular pediments up above to give it some
variety.
And you'll also see something very interesting here,
which is although the architect has used the traditional language of Greek
architecture columns and pediments and the like,
which is very traditional when you compare it to the sorts of concrete buildings
going up in Rome,
uh,
but at the same time has injected motion into this facade,
by having a series of projecting bays,
receiving base,
projecting bay receding bay,
creating a kind of undulating,
uh,
in out effect across the facade.
And then has done something quite interesting,
which is to place the columns in the second tier,
not immediately above those in the lower tier,
but straddling the spaces in between them above the receding bays rather than
the projecting bays,
which injects still more a motion into the upper part of the structure in
contrast to the lower part.
Uh,
so you can,
and you can see also the,
the again,
a marble construction here,
very gated marble used for the columns.
Uh,
so very much a marble building and marble,
a very high quality marble was more readily accessible,
uh,
in Greece and an Asia minor than anywhere else in the Roman world.
This is another wonderful view.
We're standing below looking up from the first tier to the second tier of the
library of calcis.
And as you look at this,
you probably are thinking,
hey,
architectural cages at the top of fourth style Roman wall painting.
We've seen this before,
but only in painting,
we haven't seen anything like it.
The closest we got is our look at the forum transitory and more the forum of
Nerva in Rome where I showed you those columns,
that project out of the wall,
uh,
and have projecting and tablatures and that kind of in and out of fact.
I said that was the first example in Rome of what we might call borough,
the Baroque trend,
uh,
in Roman architecture where this witness motion is injected into the facade,
but we see this very naturally in Asia minor over and over again.
We see it here.
So an example of something and build architecture that we've seen earlier in
painted architecture,
uh,
and which is going to have,
is we'll see,
I have an entire lecture on the Baroque Architecture Roman antiquity,
where we look at a series of buildings around the provinces that all make use of
traditional vocabulary,
but use it in a very vibrant way,
as you can see here.
And then there is,
as you probably already noticed,
statutes that are placed in the niches on the facade.
In this case of two women.
I mean,
the interesting question for anyone working at who are these,
uh,
their names are given or they're there,
they have inscriptions down below identification in Greek.
Uh,
and you can also see with these details how elaborate these were,
how they just like in the shrine and the temple of Hadrian and emphasis the use
of decoration.
Uh,
covers almost every available space and helps to not only decorate or ornament,
but d materialize the architectural elements.
Something again,
we saw on painting third style Roman painting.
Here we see it and on the Aarp Ahca.
So we have seen it in architecture here.
We see it in architecture in the western empire.
Another very interesting city and issue,
uh,
is uh,
in the Roman city of Jericho or Jerash in what is today,
Jordan.
Uh,
I show you,
we will look at a couple of buildings in Jordan later in the term,
but not at this particular one.
I show you a plan of what the Roman city of Gera Gerrish looked like and where
the Roman buildings were located.
You can pick out all the obvious components of a miniature Rome.
You see a hippodrome,
for example,
over here with its hairpin shape.
There was an arch of Hadrian over here.
Uh,
there was,
there were two theaters,
the north theater over here,
and there's another theater somewhere there,
the south theater up there.
And you can see that,
that they conform to the shape of a typical Roman theater.
Uh,
you also see there was a temple artimus here as well.
There are a couple of to trap salons we haven't seen to trap a lawns in Rome.
And in fact the Romans didn't build tech trap Alonzo in the city.
Uh,
Ted Trap Alon is a four sided arch that is made specifically to span two streets
so that you can go through the arch and the arch is right over the intersection
of those two streets so that you can draw,
you can drive your cart or walk right through.
Uh,
the arch on either street,
either of the two streets,
these to trap a were very popular in the eastern part of the empire.
Will see a number of,
we'll see if a couple of them today and others in the course of the term.
And you see that here and for anybody interested both in Jerash and into trap
Alonzo.
I recommend,
I'm not going over this specific references here,
but if you don't,
you probably didn't bring this today,
but on the web portal you will find bibliography for each one of these topics.
And again,
as I mentioned,
most of these are on reserve for the course.
I recommend in particular the book by William McDonald called the architecture
of the Roman Empire volume to,
uh,
in which he focuses specifically anyone working on one of the cities in the
east.
And Eastern provinces will find this book very valuable because he,
he,
uh,
in very poetic language,
he is able to conjure up a,
the way in which these cities were planned,
the way in which these buildings,
uh,
interacted with the streets of the city.
Uh,
and um,
and,
and the,
the kind of,
um,
vistas and visual,
visual,
uh,
kind of views that were,
that were,
um,
that were carefully orchestrated by the designers of these cities as well as the
ways in which they wanted to move people around those cities.
I think you'll find that book,
uh,
particularly valuable.
Now,
what's,
uh,
let me just go back for a moment.
I just want to show you that plan one more time because eventually I am going to
show you,
uh,
the forum of Jaris of what you see is located right over here.
Uh,
and the shape of that forum is particularly interesting as we shall see just a
couple of buildings from uh,
Jaris,
uh,
on the left hand side of the screen,
the arch of Hadrian,
which you can once again stone construction here,
uh,
with um,
large projecting columns,
niches on the second story,
contrast between larger order and smaller order.
Here we again see projecting columns with projecting and tablature,
but then a pediment,
uh,
that is recessed.
So again,
this playing around with the traditional language of architecture in a way the
Greeks themselves would not have done.
Uh,
same happens up here.
You have project look tall projecting columns with a triangular pediment,
but a triangular pediment that is made up of projecting wings on either side.
And then the central part of the pediment is,
is,
uh,
is uh,
placed in depth here,
a view of the fountain or the Nim Fam of the city of Jericho where you can see
again the use just as the library of Kelsey's,
the use of columns in this case sets of columns that are placed one on top of
the other.
And two tiers.
There would have been a columnar display here,
probably certainly also in two stories on the interior of this building.
Now this is the,
this is the part of Jared Jared said that I think is most interesting and that
is that it has an oval forum,
an Oval Forum,
a forum in an oval shape.
Now we've seen ovals before for amphitheater architecture,
the elliptical plan of an amphitheater,
but we have not seen,
and we've seen octagonal rooms and we've seen round rooms,
but we have not seen the Romans in Italy use,
uh,
the,
um,
the oval a for anything other than amphitheater architecture.
And yet we see here this wonderful forum and Jarrod said that consists of an
oval,
which is defined essentially by a series of columns on a curve.
So placing of Colin's flanks,
placing of the traditional language of Greek architecture along a curve,
um,
which we've seen before.
We saw that at Palestrina,
uh,
for example,
but we see it,
uh,
here with this oval shape.
And the other thing that you see in this view that is so interesting is the fact
that many,
most of the streets in the cities in the eastern provinces are colonated
streets.
Our streets that have columns all along them.
We never ever see this in Italy.
There is no ancient Roman,
a town in Italy that has a colonated street.
So we begin to see these interesting differences,
uh,
between Rome and the province is why is this,
I mean it's interesting to ask ourselves why this might be.
I think again,
it probably has to do with the fact that there was a long tradition and in
Greece and in Asia minor for a Greek architecture,
Greek architecture made out of stone using columns for the most part.
Uh,
and uh,
that was something that they were used to.
They liked it,
uh,
and they continued it on,
but they beget,
but they began to do it in a different way.
I'm,
the Greeks would never have built a,
an oval oval meeting or mar marketplace.
Uh,
but here we see the oval.
So this combination of the idea of the oval probably from amphitheater
architecture combined with the traditional language,
traditional vocabulary of Greek marble architecture.
Another extraordinary site is the site of Paul Myra,
uh,
which is in PA L P A,
l m,
Y,
r a,
which is in modern Syria.
Uh,
and I show you a view of the ancient remains of Palmyra as they look today.
And you can immediately see that pal Myra,
just like Jaris a has colonated streets.
Here's the street.
You can see all of the columns,
uh,
along it as well as a series of large buildings that are part of the Roman
structures that were added to the city of Palmyra in Roman times.
Here's an example of one.
This is a stone arch,
uh,
at Pell Myra.
And you can see that the stone arch has been made part of that colonated street
and the columns that lead up to it create a very interesting vista toward the
arch.
And then you can see this is very interesting.
We also see this quite commonly in the eastern part of the empire.
Not only do they have columns,
but they placed brackets on those columns that project out from them.
Uh,
and those brackets were meant to help hold honorific statuary.
So statues of some of the famous people of the city or magistrates or whatever
of the city of a Roman Pell Myra.
I mentioned a ted trap,
Alanna foresighted arch that would span two streets.
We see one of those here are very well preserved to trap alon in Pell Myra.
And you see that at once again,
they don't use the traditional language of architecture made out of stone with
columns supporting straight lentils that serve and placed on a stone bases.
As you can see here that serve as the four a sides of that to trap along.
There would have been some roof on top of this of some sort or maybe not.
That's I forgotten whether that was the forgotten what people think about this
particular arch,
whether there was,
some of them have,
uh,
have roofs and some of them do not.
I don't actually recall what the case is with this one.
Uh,
but it gives you,
again,
a very good idea of this to travel on arch that was so popular in the eastern
part of the empire.
But the building again in Pal Myra that I think is by far the most intriguing
and makes a perfect paper topic because one can try to decode a what,
which aspects of this are Roman and which aspects of this are local.
And that's essentially the name of the game when you tried,
when you go out into the Roman provinces to try to determine what it is,
you know,
what in what ways has the,
uh,
has what's going on in the capitol,
had impact on what's happening in the provinces and what local traditions are so
strong that they continue to exist and even resurface in some of these
buildings.
It's usually a coming together of both of those elements,
elements from Rome and local elements and the way in which those coexist and
ended up,
uh,
creating an entirely different architectural phenomenon,
which is what we see in this building here.
This is called the temple of Bell,
B e l at Palmyra,
again in modern Syria.
And you say to yourself,
well,
who is bell?
Uh,
well,
bell is a God and that that tells you something already.
Bell is a local God.
Uh,
so this is not a temple to Jupiter or to the cat or to Jupiter,
Juno and Manurewa.
This is a temple to bell.
So that already tells us something,
uh,
about,
this structure when it,
as it goes up in Rome that they are as it goes up in Palmyra during Roman Times
that they are interested in commemorating and honoring,
uh,
a local God.
If we look at the plan,
and maybe you can help me here with this,
if we look at the plan a and we think back to what we know,
uh,
of typical Greek that trust skin and Roman temple architecture,
we should be struck by this plan.
What,
what is it that strikes us?
What elements strike us about this particular plant?
Yup.
The,
the porch,
the staircase,
the PA,
the podium.
You mean the podium,
The podium goes all the way around and the columns go all the way around and you
can see in this restored view,
the staircase,
it goes all the way around.
So the podium,
the staircase,
and the columns which are freestanding as you can see here,
go all the way around.
So that is characteristic of what kind of temple architecture,
Greek,
Greek temple architecture.
However,
what else do we see that's curious?
This is not entirely a Greek temple type.
It's,
Yup.
The seller
Sella is here.
We have a single seller,
we have a staircase
on what an additional staircase on one side,
uh,
which leads into the seller from the side,
not from the end,
but as we usually say,
you know,
usually enter from one end,
one short end,
and you have the apps or,
or the,
um,
the place where the God statue was kept on the other side.
But here we see a staircase,
it's placed in the center and it isn't even quite in the center.
It's actually slightly off center on one of the long sides of the temple,
which we have never seen before.
Uh,
so we have this interesting location of the stack of the other,
but also this combination of a staircase that goes all the way around in the
Greek manner,
but then a kind of facade orientation by the placement of an additional
staircase on one side of the monument.
So very schizophrenia,
a building in that regard.
And the list goes on and on.
Let's look at the restored view.
What do we see here that's curious?
Anyone
we have
Paul columns with capital's look at the doorway.
Can you see,
I don't know how clear it is to you from where you sit,
what's happening above the doorway.
We have additional,
we have the upper part of the,
of the column and the Capitol truncated,
placed on top of the doorway.
That strange.
How are we meant to read that?
Exactly.
We've never seen that before.
And look at the top,
we have crenelations on the top of the monument.
Uh,
and at the very top we have some kind of a deck up there.
that must,
that may have been used for something having to do with the worship of bell.
Uh,
so one asks one.
So we see this interesting combination of Greek,
uh,
the influence of Greek temple architecture,
Roman temple architecture and local practice.
Uh,
and so one would want to ask one's self and one would try to find out what one
could about the worship of bell and about their,
whether there were any earlier temples of bell here and whether any of these
features have to do with local,
uh,
a local practice.
The building still stands,
are part of it.
Uh,
and you can see it here.
Here you see that doorway,
uh,
that we were looking at just before some of the columns.
And you can see the kind of very,
uh,
nice honey colored a stone out of which the temple of belt was made.
Another terrific topic.
And for anybody who lives on the west coast and is going home to the La area,
a four break,
uh,
if you,
you probably have already been to the Getty museum,
it could go again,
but if you have never been,
it's an extraordinary,
this would be a perfect time to go.
Uh,
the villa of the Papiri in Herculaneum Avila.
comparable to some of the villas that we've looked at this semester,
whether it's bus go Trey Causey or the village Ovis on Coppery,
uh,
a very important villa in Campania,
of the early Roman period.
Uh,
the villa up a period of,
of,
of the Papiri is so called because of papayas fragments that were found there.
The owner of this particular villa had his own library.
We're back to libraries again.
And I,
by the way,
on the bibliography,
there's a particularly good book by Lionel case in c a s s o n on the libraries
of the ancient world that anybody who works either on emphasis or this will
probably want to take a look at.
Uh,
he has his own library here and there were scrolls from that library,
especially from one specific author that were found there.
Uh,
and it is because of those papayas fragments that the villa got its name,
the villa of the Papiri in Herculaneum.
Uh,
the excavations excavations were done some time ago of this villa.
the a plan was drawn of the villa at that particular time,
but the excavators found that noxious gases were starting to be emitted from the
ground and there was a great,
it was a health hazard.
And so after they unearthed it,
after they drew it,
they covered it back over again.
And it's only been in very recent years.
That excavation has again began on this site.
And I show you a couple of views of the excavation that is currently underway
that is once again revealing some of the original walls as well as some of the
stucco and paintings of the original villa.
Now what's particularly interesting and where the Getty Museum comes in is John
Paul Getty,
when he designed his,
his villa at Malibu,
which serves of course as a museum of antiquities,
uh,
when he was building that he used,
the villa of the Papiri as a model.
And I mean,
as an exact model,
he really duplicated quite a precisely the bill of the [inaudible].
This is the plan of the Ville of the Papiri as it was drawn when it was
originally excavated.
And you can see,
I guess if the of the structures we looked at,
it's probably most like the house of Lorraine Teper Tina's,
where you'll remember this,
a small amount of space given to the House on two stories and most of it given
to a large garden.
We see the same idea here where we have a,
and you could see it better over here where we have a one area around a court
that has living spaces on the second story.
And then the rest of the villa is taken up in this case by a huge,
hugely long pool,
uh,
that has statuary and the like around it.
Now,
John Paul Getty decided again to use,
uh,
this Ville of the period as the model for the Getty villa.
Uh,
and this is actually the Getty villa that you're looking at here from the error,
a painting of the Getty villa that you see from the air here.
And you can see that it is almost exactly the same and plan as the actual villa
of the Papiri.
So going to the Getty villa,
and this is of course a view of that long pool.
At the Getty villa,
going to the Getty villa is like going back in time to the Ville of the Papiri.
And I know a lot of people think this is sort of Disneyland in Malibu or Roman
version of Disneyland.
Yes,
to a certain extent.
But the truth of the matter is you will get a better sense of what a Roman villa
looked like.
Enrollment antiquity from going and looking at the Getty villa.
Then you will get from going and looking at the villa of the mysteries at palm
pay only because they have restored it because it is in such good condition and
because they have added to it the kind of plants that would have been used
there,
the paintings are in good shape.
They've placed statuary,
actual copies of the ancient statuary that would have been at the bill of that.
The period cause hundreds of statues from the Ville of the preparer have
survived.
Uh,
and uh,
they have,
you can see them all at the Getty.
I'm going to show you a few views of this because I think it's such an
interesting topic.
I mean,
I think one could write a very interesting paper on the original villa as seen
through the eyes of the Getty Museum.
Uh,
for those of you who have either been there or have not been or have never been
there,
just a few views.
The entrance way into the villa today,
one of the ramps they have,
just if you saw this a few years ago and haven't been back,
they have made some additions in the last several years,
uh,
including their version of a theater.
Uh,
and you can see it here in ancient theater,
which you can see here with the caveat with the coup nay or wedge shaped
sections of seats to very good restaurants up above.
Uh,
and then this is a view standing up on the top of the coffee,
of looking down toward the orchestra,
toward the stage building,
which is of course,
part of the Getty villa itself.
Uh,
and uh,
you see also that the,
it's very accurate.
I mean,
it looks,
it looks a little too new,
but it's very accurate and that they have even used here.
Uh,
the,
uh,
typical columns with the white top and the red bottom,
that we saw.
So characteristic of a architecture in palm pay and also in Herculaneum and a
view of another pool with some famous,
uh,
copies of some famous bronze dancers from Herculaneum.
I'll show you the originals in a moment.
This is the Getty's version of first style Roman wall painting,
uh,
along the walls.
Uh,
as you can see here,
it's not quite the same,
but nonetheless,
it conjures up a what one of these walls would have looked like if you had it.
Uh,
you know,
all the way along your corridor and they have second style Roman wall painting
as well.
And these of course base,
they,
they look mostly at the villa,
but when it came to the paintings,
they certainly used other models.
And you,
if you walk around the villa,
you'll be able to,
oh yeah.
That comes from the um,
the,
um,
this is a very,
our apoc is like a motif with the garland on the columns and so on here.
So second,
a style wall painting.
In this particular case.
Here's another example of second style wall painting at the Getty where they
have wonderfully incorporated the door and two of the windows into this second
style scheme.
As you can see here.
Uh,
and here we were dealing with um,
an atrium in the Getty museum,
which is based I think on,
on a building that I'm sure you all know know and learned for the exam,
which is which,
which house?
The Atrium of which house,
which
Betty
I think Betty,
what about this second story up here?
Sam [inaudible] Sam night,
the Sam Night House with its second story in the low Jah.
Uh,
and then with its,
with its improving them and it's comp bluebeam.
I'm,
this is,
this is a,
this is really good stuff.
And then here,
here you see a view of one of the pools,
uh,
looking through the doors here,
they would've had the wooden door jams.
We saw those in Herculaneum preserved,
uh,
through that to the pool with the dancing women and men.
At the very end you see a fountain that is based exactly on the large fountain.
I showed it to you earlier this term.
At palm pay.
Uh,
and here this whole concept of Vista Panorama from one part of the house to
another taking advantage of light streaming through the comp pluvial onto the
pool.
Reflections in that pool statuary.
I mean this really conjures up,
as I said,
better uh,
than anything.
I can show you what an ancient Roman villa actually looked like.
There are rooms like this at the Getty with marble incrustation that is very
much like both marble incrustation we've seen and also like for style Roman wall
painting,
uh,
areas like this where you can see again the columns surrounding the garden with
a rooms on the second story,
paintings for style paintings on the wall,
statuary in the center and all of this,
again based on the actual statuary that was found,
a great,
a huge collection of statutes at this particular owner had that are now on view
and the archeological museum in Naples where copied a for this here.
And then just another view showing that they too at the Getty Villa Malibu,
we're very cognizant of the siding of the structure,
placing it on a cliff,
you know,
so that you can have a beautiful panorama,
uh,
down from there.
Very much in line with the way the Romans cited their buildings.
And then just quickly,
just to give you a sense of how compelling,
uh,
some of the sculpture is from here.
These are the originals.
This is the head of an original athlete or gladiatorial figure,
uh,
from Herculaneum.
And you can see how vivid it is,
especially it's done in bronze,
but especially with the inlaid eyes that were customary for statues of this
type.
This has got to be the best hair,
uh,
in Roman art.
I love this one,
a fantastic fan,
fantastically dramatic photo of this particular head that also comes from the
villa at the ability of the Papiri.
And here are dancing ladies.
These are the original versions of the dancing women that would have surrounded
a,
a pool in the actual villa at Herculaneum,
extremely well preserved and in every possible posture.
As you can see here.
Uh,
if bill the architecture is your thing,
but you're not interested in the Getty or in or in Herculaneum,
but are,
uh,
an anglophile and want to do something in England.
I've got two topic,
two British topics.
We're not going to look at Roman art in Britain.
So for any of you who are particularly interested in art in the British isles
is,
might be a good topic for you.
I have both a villa and a bath.
This is the Roman villa at Fishburne and Sussex,
England.
It's a model of what that villa would have looked like.
And you can see that it has a lot in common with the template pockets in Rome
with it's great rectangular space.
And one of the buildings push back against it.
Uh,
but one of the questions one would ask for this is for any buildings that were
done somewhere other than Rome,
what is based in,
how close is this to what's going on in Rome contemporaneously?
Uh,
and what is different?
What has to do with local practice?
Uh,
if one visits the,
um,
fish born villa today,
you can still see the mosaic floors,
uh,
that are WellPreserved here.
Uh,
and you can also,
here's the detail of one of them,
which is touted as the,
um,
the older,
the oldest to be seen,
the earliest to be seen anywhere in Britain as you can see from the label.
Uh,
and you can even see it at the,
uh,
fish born villa for example,
a private bath,
uh,
with the hypo costs.
So clearly the impact of Rome is clear here and they even have a such a such
element's preserved as these roof tiles that you can see here on the right hand
side.
Another British topic,
a is the Roman bath and bath.
I'll quite soulless.
Now in Avon,
England,
this is a view of a magnet,
the magnificent city of bath itself as it looks today.
And here's a view of what a part of what is preserved of the Roman bath at bath,
the water as green as the Tiber,
as you can see in this view.
Uh,
but this is part of the bath structure.
And again,
what one would ask oneself is,
and there are,
there's enough there that plans plans of what this Beth would have looked like a
exist and one would ask oneself,
you know,
what,
what is this?
What,
what,
how does this compare to bas that we saw in Italy?
What is it,
you know,
how does it compare to the bath that Pompei the forum bas or they stop being
best to the imperial bath architecture of Titus,
similar kinds of rooms.
What is the construction technique?
Who was this useful?
Who did this belong to?
Who put this up and,
and what,
what part did it play in the social and cultural environment of the city?
Uh,
and have acquired soulist in ancient Roman times,
another view of that where you can see some of the stone construction.
And then once again,
a very WellPreserved hypo cost,
uh,
at,
the,
uh,
at the bath and bath as well as a very interesting,
brick arch that you can see here.
So the whole question of technology,
what kind of technology is used in buildings?
Like this is an intriguing question.
Another great topic.
If you want to make your way to the Middle East to Masada.
Uh,
this is the famous cliff at Masada.
I don't know how many of you have climbed.
How many of you have climbed Masada?
Anyone climb this out?
A couple of you.
I did.
You go on the snake path
saying you're sober.
I didn't go on this eye and I was there a long time ago,
so I should have gone on this path,
but I didn't.
I went on the cable cars.
So here,
you know,
this is what you do when you go and you take the easy way out.
Just take the cable car up.
Uh,
but you can get some good pictures of other cable cars as well as of the
mountain as you make your way.
The thing to do is definitely to take the snake path,
uh,
up to the top of the peak of Masada,
which is steeped in history as we know.
The particular aspect,
uh,
that would be at issue here,
would be to look at the,
uh,
Herod's Palace,
the Great Herod who about whom much is known,
very interesting historical per character who was around in the first century
BC,
the time of Julius Caesar and Cleopatra.
And so on his palace at Massada,
which was built on the top of the peak is particularly interesting given its
date.
It's roughly contemporary to the sorts of things we saw going on in Italy,
had Palestrina and at Tivoli,
the,
uh,
the um,
the,
the placement of,
of nutcase,
the pouring of concrete on a tiered hillside,
uh,
in this case use of different materials as you can see here.
But two views of what the Palace of,
uh,
Herod on Masada would have looked like.
Again,
a tiered structure,
multi,
multi tiered structure through roughly three tiers.
So the question here is,
you know,
what did he have in mind?
Why did he put it here?
Why did he choose to represent it as a kind of cascading structure from top to
bottom?
How does it compare to Palestrina and Tivoli?
Uh,
what is it made of?
Is it made of concrete or is it made of something else?
And why,
uh,
in each instance,
what kind of architectural elements are used in this particular case?
And if I show you a couple of details,
you will see that Rome is not too far away in the sense that once again we see a
hypercar system being used to heat the floor of this particular room in Herod's
Palace.
Was this a bath or was this something else?
Remember we saw the hypo cost also used to heat the floor of the missions,
um,
dining room in his palace in Rome.
And then over here look wall painting,
very similar to what we see in Italy,
uh,
at roughly the same time.
This is again,
BC.
So we're talking about,
uh,
first and especially second style Roman wall painting or the transition between
first and second style Roman wall painting tombs.
We've seen tombs are particularly interesting as a topic because they're so
varied and have so much to do with the particular patrons who commissioned them.
I showed you fleetingly,
the two tombs streets at palm pay,
the via De supple Gri and the via new Chera.
Uh,
and I told you that we would concentrate instead on tombs in Rome,
but they make a very interesting paper topic for someone who'd like to think
further about palm pay.
And to think about the variety of tool,
market texture in Pompei that varies from house tombs that look like houses to
tombs that have columns in the second story was statues interspersed among them,
uh,
to uh,
tombs that again have a niche in the center with statuary,
unfortunately headless here,
but it PR prescript preserved inscriptions.
So if you want to get into who these people were,
what we know about them,
a kind of cultural study,
you could do that.
And this is my favorite tomb on the via new and palm pay because it should
remind you of something we saw earlier when we looked at Roman to marketecture.
What was that?
The columbaria,
the column Barton,
the Bgr Codine but you'll remember that scheme of placing niches on a wall was
for subterranean to architecture in Rome.
And here we see it's,
it's just a great idea.
I mean,
they took the idea of the columbarium and they slapped it on the front,
on the facade of a tomb.
So you see two tiers here of niches,
same kind of portraits that we saw or earns that we saw in the Venia codine comp
columbaria and brought above ground,
same kind of inscriptions in front of each of them and made into a,
the facade of this very interesting facade of a two a on the via new Chera in
Pompei residential architecture in the Roman provinces,
the houses in France at a place called a Vasovagal Algoma men Bozzio Volcom to
your arm in antiquity.
Uh,
the,
uh,
the French tout this as,
the French Pompei.
It is far from the French Pompei unfortunately because it doesn't have all of
those public buildings.
It doesn't have an amphitheater or theater or,
oh,
Deon or you know,
so on and so forth.
But it does have some interesting houses.
The houses are not as well preserved as those in Pompei.
Uh,
but it's interesting to look at them.
This is a model of one of them,
uh,
showing the same sort of elements that we've seen in Italy.
The,
uh,
Paris.
Dot.
This is the hellenized don't mistype Paris dial cord over here,
uh,
the [inaudible] of the Atrium over here.
So it gives you,
and then down on this end,
a colonnade with a pool in front of it.
So in a very similar to the kinds of things that we saw in palm pay,
uh,
this is a view of some of the,
of the ancient houses as they look today.
And as they make,
as they make up part of the modern town,
uh,
that surrounds them in amazing on the whole men,
you can see that they're not,
they're preserved only,
you know,
Melanie,
the foundation's essentially are preserved,
but enough of them are to give us a very good sense of the plans,
the architectural plans of these.
And it can be interesting to look at these in connection to what we have from
Pompei and to see how they stack up and whether they are different in any way
because of the fact that they were put up and what was ancient goal and not in
Italy.
And here a a a view of one of the peristyle courts of one of those as well as
um,
a mosaic.
And if you look at the what remains of the wall painting,
you can see that that is completely consistent with what's going on in Italy.
At the same time.
Option two,
I'm not going to go into in any detail,
but you'll see when you look on the website for option two,
that that's called selective building.
Select a theme if there is nothing here that you liked,
but you do want to do a research paper.
Uh,
and there is some building that you've seen on your travels that we haven't
talked about in this course or even a building that we have talked about in this
course,
but talked about in a few minutes time that you would like to a paper on.
For some reason you may do that.
Uh,
and you would do it in the same way that you do the first one.
It would be a research paper.
You do re you will need to get permission from me to chew.
You know which one you choose.
You can do this either directly to me by email or by the teaching fellows.
You could go to them and uh,
they,
they will likely be able to be my surrogate surrogate if the idea is good and if
they have any concerns,
they will let me know and we'll talk about it and we'll let you know would only
be the reason I want you to come to us is just because if we think that there's
absolutely no,
you know,
there's nothing to read on it.
It won't,
it's going to be very hard for you to do.
We want you to alert you to that.
We want to make sure you choose something where there's a lot of,
a lot to think about and a lot to do.
Um,
that will be a fruitful experience for you.
So that's option two.
And then option three is by far,
oh,
I forgot one.
I'm sorry.
Very quickly.
The last topic,
under number one,
the a tower tombs at Pal Myra.
We already talked about Palmyra in Syria.
You see that these tombs here,
a very distinctive,
these tall tower like tombs,
which is why they're called tower tombs.
Here's one of them here,
made out of local stone,
very stark.
Uh,
usually with,
uh,
a niche in the center that sometimes has a representation of a deceased member
of the family lying on a bed.
Uh,
and here are the interior of one of these very ornate coffered ceiling with
paintings,
with portrait paintings and the top,
and then a series of niches where you see a poor,
either single portraits or group portraits of members of the same family.
Sort of like what we saw on the outside of tombs on the,
via Apia in this case,
on the inside of tombs.
This would be an interesting topic for someone who would also like to use to go
actually look at something at the yellow art gallery because we have,
uh,
some of the portraits that come from these pal Myreen tombs in the Yale Art
Gallery.
I show you one example of one of those here.
The last topic,
my favorite by far,
and I really urge this is a tremendous amount of fun.
So I really urge as many of you as possible,
who would like to be truly creative,
uh,
to choose this topic.
It's design your own Roman city.
Uh,
you're an architect,
a city planner,
you're competing for the major commission of your lifetime.
I'll let you read the rest of that on the website of a colony of 10,000 people.
You can build this anywhere in the Roman world that you want a,
so if there's a particular place you've enjoyed vacationing and you want to put
it there because you know that place,
well,
that's fine.
Uh,
and you can almost do anything that you want to do.
You can be as creative and as Zany as you want to be as you do this.
Uh,
the only thing that I ask,
and you do need to do a paper along with this as well,
which is a paper that you'll see from the,
so they can need to be drawings which are either hand drawn or computer
generated.
Uh,
that would usually include the city plan itself,
although it doesn't have to and as selection of building.
So it's going to take you some time to do.
Obviously if you're skilled at drawing or you're an architecture major,
you're going to be able to do this more readily than someone else.
But I just want to urge those.
You don't have,
we have,
we had one project with basically with stick figures one time.
That was really fantastic.
So I mean,
even if your drawing skills are not great,
it's the ideas that will we be impressed by great drawings.
You Bet we will.
But,
but I don't want to discourage anyone for whom drawing is not your forte because
I think it's really the ideas that count the creativity that counts,
uh,
here.
Uh,
but you can choose any,
any location.
Oh,
I mentioned that there's a paper that has described the colony,
the reason for its construction,
giving,
giving it's name and again,
be very creative here.
Uh,
it's date,
its location,
Italy or the provinces.
You can pretty much put anything you want in these cities.
But in that paper you have to explain why.
For example,
if you were to build a town in Asia minor and it were to be filled with concrete
buildings,
which none of these towns were,
you have to explain why this particular town is filled with concrete buildings
and,
and you can come up with is crazy and explanation of that as possible.
In fact,
the crazier the better.
Uh,
but,
uh,
you need to explain something like that so that we understand that,
you know,
there was no concrete architecture in this part of the world,
but this,
this particular town is special because of the following reasons.
So I think you can see how your creative juices can flow.
I just want to show you very quickly in the,
in the five or six minutes that remain a series of these that were done by
students over time just to serve as that.
I hope they won't be intimidating but rather to serve as an inspiration there a
couple of them along the way that were done by students of architecture that are
particularly good in terms of the drawings but others,
others you'll see are quite simple and I want to show you,
so to not be intimidated by this particular topic,
this is a wonderful acidity that someone created a on a harbor,
you can see the docs,
you can also see the port authority that has been added here as well as the
warehouses.
There's some misspellings like Conoco July over here,
uh,
living in Bas,
I guess after Olivia.
But look at this wonderful forum where we have a temple pushed up against one of
the back walls.
For some reason there's a touch trap alon in the middle of the forum,
which kind of works for this street,
but I'm not exactly sure where it goes here,
but it's an interesting motif.
And then this market,
this would have infesting circular and market,
that kind of projects on one side creating a very interesting shape.
Uh,
it gives you some idea,
but I've been a very regular plan.
As you can see for this particular city.
This was done by a graduate student actually in the architecture school is a
very extraordinary drawings and it was a huge plant.
Uh,
but,
but just to show you again how creative it was,
the city of Altos after Mars old tour of course.
Uh,
and you can see,
uh,
some wonderful motifs in a and a and a and you know,
all of them identified here,
this large temple I to trap along.
There's always a fascination with to trap Alonzo and this project,
uh,
some other structures over here including a marketplace at seven,
but I love it.
Six the Korea.
You never see a round Korea,
but this is a round Korea,
which is absolutely terrific.
Uh,
opening off the basilica,
which you see over here,
which is very closely based on Basilican architecture of the tray Janick period
and into the seven period.
It's an interesting wedge shape.
Shops over here.
So again,
it gives you some sense of what's possible.
This is not by an architecture student,
but a very,
another one of these port,
uh,
port,
cities,
uh,
that has a,
I the love this,
the sunken theater.
You can see the sunken theater that goes right into the sea over here on this
side,
but as well as the port,
you can see this was a Flavian.
So again,
you got to decide where you want to put it,
which period,
the Flavian a period.
So a Flavi and port city.
Uh,
this I a another one also,
I think from that same project where you can see the Flavian basilica,
I Aye,
a capitalism with a temple to Jupiter,
Juno and Minerva.
And then Titus is honored over here with his statue and a couple of victory
statues.
Uh,
one on either side.
Again,
I think from the same project,
uh,
this is the city itself where you can see it has an amphitheater.
Uh,
it has a basilica on a forum and it also has a colonated courtyard,
a colonated street.
If you build a colonated street in a town in Italy,
you got to explain why this is the only colonated street in the,
in a town in Italy.
If you put it in the east,
it's,
it's obvious same,
same project.
I think again,
the should be the tear,
my tt and the library.
But I love this because the person has identified the stone,
you know,
in the amphitheater here,
a stone has been important from all over the world,
from Syria and from emphasis,
uh,
to be used in this particular structure and arch.
Again,
I think also this was a very ambitious project in arch from that same project
with a victory at the top and an inscription.
Uh,
and then this,
the victory gate again with the amphitheater in the background.
This was something simpler but interesting.
A small fountain composite capitals,
coffered misspelled apps,
a philosopher pose of Titus scalped pool,
uh,
with the triple basin.
This one very simple and very derivative in a way,
but I love this one.
Anyway.
Uh,
this house plan shows us that the person was basing it on which house it was
actually on the exam.
Although you didn't see the plan
how's of the mosaic atrium,
because remember the up at the top,
the entrance way,
the Atrium and the Ecos at the far end in the form of a basilica.
So,
you know,
very derivative plan.
But I just love this touch.
There's just this touch did it for me.
Sticking those two palm trees in the center of the,
uh,
of the,
of the Paris Dell court was great and I forget again exactly where this town
was,
but it had something to do with that particular,
you know,
the kinds of flora and fauna of that particular part of the world.
This was another wonderful bond,
a big city plan,
a huge,
you know,
huge piece of Oak tag,
uh,
with the entire city,
a city of the seven period Rivera's with buildings,
honor,
honoring him and his son car call up,
for example.
But,
uh,
this one,
because if Timmy is severities,
his wife was particularly interested in astrological signs and used to tell him
each day what his day was going to be like based on those signs.
Uh,
the student,
uh,
incorporated,
um,
uh,
elements of the mithratic mysteries and those astrological signs,
as you can see here in many of these buildings,
uh,
in Mithraic garden and so on and so forth,
which was really wonderful.
This was great.
This was someone who made a book,
a book,
uh,
and,
included in,
it was kind of a treasure map,
you know,
that included a preamble to where this city was and interspersed within this and
we made,
was made to look very old as if it was just discovered,
uh,
by,
you know,
by Harrison Ford himself.
Uh,
and,
and we see,
we see the,
these wonderful plans interspersed with the text.
Then this a small,
simple house again with some wonderful wall paintings of,
I guess the third style.
And this my absolute favorites still to this day.
This was done very well.
I probably in the early eighties when I began teaching a version of this course
in the early eighties by a student,
uh,
who,
um,
is Petrus Greenberg IOUs,
Peter Greenberg,
uh,
who,
who presented his project in the form of a scroll.
He knew very well.
There were no books at this time.
There were scrolls.
And so he presented this long scroll.
I can't even imagine how long this text took him to write on this scroll,
but it was a long scroll and it came and it was,
you know,
was tied up with a what nice ribbon and so on and so forth.
And you unfurled it and it had the text all about his town.
And,
uh,
you know,
he,
he was the architect,
if I remember correctly,
the designer,
and he was presenting his case to the emperor or to the empress and like,
you know,
me,
uh,
so he was presenting his,
he was presenting his case,
um,
to me about this city that he wanted to build and was I going to give him
permission to build it?
So interspersed with this text where these wonderful drawings of what he had in
mind.
So,
I mean,
there are so many ways,
is one of many,
many wonderful ones that I've gotten.
I hope this will be inspirational to you.
Uh,
I can't say have a great break quite yet because we have class on Thursday.
but I know you're all looking forward to it,
and I hope that your travels can in some way,
uh,
include,
even if you're just going to the beach in Cannes cone,
I hope it can include in some way some thinking about buildings and about this
project.
Thank you.